[Music]
catching the fish is definitely
the biggest element
favorite part is always to take you know
when the fish takes the fly
adrenaline just goes off
just
casting
running your own business and all of a
sudden
that's a lot of fun
[Applause]
we're at tunguefield
which is a sea turtle river on the south
coast of iceland
this river is known for for very big
fish i think it's because of all the
glaciers and this is fairly new
geologically all this
this part of the country
it's fun being fishing in this kind of
weather
once you have your first fish it starts
to be a lot more about the nature the
river
the
the company
[Music]
and being outside
getting away from your normal life
really
doing something else for two or three
days
or a week
[Music]
that's what it's all about
fly fishing offers a never-ending
journey so to speak although it sounds
like cliche you're never gonna master it
no matter how how hard you try no matter
how much time you spend doing it you're
never ever gonna master
you